[Music]
in no more happy-ending news how fitting
submitted by Stevie see from h-town
what's up h-town [ __ ]
Oh no more happy ending a massage parlor
was busted after hundreds of condoms
clogged the pipes Oh [ __ ] time don't
you know you're not supposed to flush
condoms down the toilet and hand ponds
its latex it doesn't disintegrate you
are destroying the environment what's
wrong with you man yeah because they
don't want you to leave the condoms in
the basket so then they can pull out to
come and have a baby with it that's why
taking out the trash put it in another
bag and thrown out somewhere else it's
the man who disposes of the condom so
it's probably him afraid they're gonna
take his semen and reproduce or sell it
oh I'm pretty sure if you're doing in
some massage Potter not that important
of a person how important do you think
you are there's like my parents
neighborhood that we grew up inside
super ghetto and these people are hiding
their ATM it's like first of all no
one's gonna steal your $12 off your bank
account maybe they are flushing it
because they don't want any evidence in
the trash yeah they were doing a
stakeout and they're like oh my god why
does this massage parlor have so much
condoms in the trash I was thinking that
do what they tell the man name when you
go to the bathroom to clean up put the
toilet either way where they can like
you know beginning you could bust the
massage parlor now because you know that
they're doing some shady [ __ ] there how
do you know it's not a legit massage
place and people are just jacking off in
the bathrooms a lot hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds with that's Hart's
condoms dude jacking off with condoms
some people are very safe it's really
cool actually that makes me feel really
good
a [ __ ] with a condo yeah it's better
practice is more like I'm gonna try to I
never tried it but that's more work for
the [ __ ] person though because of the
not saying they're doing it themselves I
think it's a legit let's take a Massage
Envy like a real [ __ ] place and then
people just keep going to the bathroom a
jacking off
use a condom for their own protection
because calluses let's say you're a
mechanic and you have oil all over your
hands right you don't put that do we we
it sounds like it's you like you give
this real elaborate story right now I
know it's like listen I'm a chili I mean
I go to the JIT places and then
afterwards you feel really relaxed so I
myself happen there's a lot of people
who can't do that
this writing says the greasy mechanic
there's the peanut butter maker the
chili farmer there's a flamin hot
cheetos eater there you go you don't
want that [ __ ] on your dick why was it
like at the top of your guys mind just
why is that list just handy I don't know
things get hot sometimes you touch your
dick after I know people that know
people one time I used pepper spray
that's just my peepee after I was to get
a peek in her that's not a fun thing to
I touched a cut jalapeno I went to go
pee and allow burn like jalapeno and
then I was touched at and I went to go
pee i marinated my bacon onions i
marinated my bacon onions are marinated
my bacon onions you guys touch your
penis every time you pee what are you
gonna whop it out yep
we're not children remember back in the
day when you could just put your pants
down and you'd be this thing and you
just look at you
doesn't complement in that he finally
got one she's watching this video right
now she doesn't appreciate me I've known
in 10 years I've never seen him blush
you gotta make your man blows Jessica I
know you're watching this she does in
many ways you know what happens though I
guarantee you the reason why is because
usually if a girl compliments the guy
like that he stops you I'm done I've
done she knows me too well motivates me
just like an Asian mother does morning
fat-ass I'll be in the mirin and I get
the fat and I push it down and I go look
I have four packs just for me and she's
like yeah can I see you every day and
I'm like oh you oh my god I gotta work
harder so this takes place in Austin and
there's this massage parlor that got
busted it's called jade muscle of course
it's Asian it would have to be what
makes you think it's Asian Jade the
[ __ ] green Asian rock of lust the
husband's name is Joseph Emery what kind
of lastly was that wasn't a white man
sounds like Mandarin Jamboree Emily
Joseph Emery Jade massage yeah that
matches he's 54 years old his wife her
name is Quan Quan one smoke detector
yeah it's just one
[Music]
juan Rodriguez on last name Wang what
Han way yeah one way I only got one way
that's what your kid's name should be
Wong Kwan water I need that one with the
10 ball tequan chen mexican me that
brands of 10 like Quan Quan oh yeah I
was trying to think it's not I could it
anyways a detective with a scientist see
the specific massage press I'd love to
investigate brothels I know about I'm
gonna recover yeah it's a little sticky
I'm gonna just a little well it has to
be the nice ones like the ones in
Australia that are like legal and then
they're like top-notch ladies that are
like thousands of dollars oh just hate
till I go in a room it's like it smells
like bleach because it's really clean or
there's a lot of coming here
Oh smells like bleach smells like bleach
that's a really flattering description
we smells terrible though yeah so anyway
this detective was assigned to
investigate Dave massage therapy and so
when they went they discovered that
there was multiple like rooms where they
found like the woman and then like
they're naked client so they pretty much
read at that place but two days before
that I got a massage when I was naked
happy Oh what is this coin he was like
you know it's just it's just me and you
so you know I was like you I know what
you're talking what he was the old
Korean guy it's different you get a good
idea no no I got Humpty boom yeah it's
comfortable
oh I thought he was like proposing
something no no the thing is I had a
couples massage with Jess with him and
then it was a lady massage but then that
was like a month ago and then when I
came back it was just me and him in the
room so then I felt more comfortable
like yeah I might just get but ask me
but due to that to me to be opposite
effect just like it's just me and you
and there
it's just me and you sir it's okay
there's no ladies in the room you know
you said it was just the me and the
years
his hands are open his bodies wave
addition yes anyways the two days before
they got raided one wing she was stopped
during security screening at the airport
in Austin after after they detected like
a large amount of money I'd never say
calm no money in her carry-on luggage
she was carrying uh like small duct-tape
bundles of cash that total that's at the
thirty thousand US dollars I could use
some a dip right now do miss tax season
right now are you thinking about that
Netherland things not really fishy
because I need some money so she told
the officers that she was on her way to
China to get a medical procedure and
that's why she needed that which money
in duct tape
yeah we're just kind of weird so then
she told them that she got the money
from Jade massage which is like her
business to her she panicked yeah that's
true so then she says that she got it
from that place where she claims to make
$20,000 a year so then when an officer
pointed out that she was carrying more
than a year's worth the salary with her
oh she didn't mask properly yeah that's
when she started getting really nervous
and she couldn't answer any more
questions after that so then she told
her officers that her husband does the
taxes she's like ready everybody ready
everyone else
the officers contact the husband and
then the husband said that the wife
keeps the money under the mattress at
home what are they doing
these are the worst criminals in the
[ __ ] world
just even if it's not the whole
operation it's like they just said hello
excuse me are you uh mr. Chad like after
his explanation they let her go to China
with the $30,000 back for two days later
when they got raided the detectives were
able to obtain warrants to search both
the business and their home and they
found sixty thousand dollars in cash
inside of a safe in their home so it's
like they had all this money so they got
charged money laundering and organized
criminal activity because they're saying
that this is pretty much like human
trafficking the fact that they were like
prostituting all these girls and that
the wife she couldn't even name any of
the girls other than one girl that had
been there for a year whoa think back
massages and sex go together yep the way
that it works is that your nerve endings
go from your head down your tail pot
your down your spine and they come out
through the lower back so when you press
on your lower back you're like
stimulating someone's genitals why is
that illegal like I think it's like
maybe they would have claimed the money
if they could just made an honest living
like rub and tugs are there for a reason
he's a fantastic woman this is why every
dude like when they're like 14 years old
he's like that's their move to get a
girl to do something with them is like
the back massage when she's not willing
oh I don't even know that that's just
watch movies and I'll just hook you up
with the massage girl think anyone at
that age knew what was going on they
just knew like let me help you relax
without really knowing on the exact
massage just like the old Netflix and
show I've explained what I wish I would
have known yeah that's what they had
like that's very typical like the wife
thing like well we'll have sex did you
massage me first kind of thing yeah you
know what it is too though like I just
don't understand how a guy can relax
during an Asian massage because they
massagers they do like
ages they all massage you they like beat
down your soul yeah how's it going guys
don't forget to like the video because
if you don't I will break your [ __ ]
legs thank you so much for the last
video don't forget to click right here
or I'll break your [ __ ] arms click
right here guys
[Music]